We've been passing through a variety of discourses concerning the nature of
identity,
the way in which identity is constructed.
Uh,
incidentally,
a with varying degrees of emphasis,
the way in which identity is constructed in literature.
I'm going to come back to this,
uh,
perhaps missing link literature,
in a minute.
But in the meantime,
I just wanted to point out something that I'm sure you've inferred for
yourselves,
namely,
that each one of these approaches to identity has a history and that the history
results in,
uh,
a recent chapter,
which is something like what you might call a deconstructive moment signifying
on theory itself such that,
uh,
the claim of theory as a mainstream discourse to hold certain views,
is something that in and of itself from a subversive perspective needs to be
deconstructed to be undermined.
Um,
again,
uh,
the idea in postcolonial studies of hybrid city as the undermining of cultural
bind binary's that is the double consciousness in which one experiences,
uh,
simultaneously a kind of identification with the state apparatus,
ah,
and a will to subvert it.
Uh,
by the way,
I thought,
I thought I'd give you another example of how that works because edifies to me,
uh,
I often,
you know,
I,
I'm sitting watching,
I don't actually watch talk shows very often,
but should I be watching a talk show?
They often,
they often invite people onto these shows whom they call professors.
And I just,
and I just wanted to point out to you the degree to which the sly civility,
the hybrids lies civility with which people are called professors,
is for a professor,
one of the most discouraging sounds in the language because they know very well
when someone is addressed by a talk show host as professor,
but they mean is you are a pen.
You don't know how to park a bicycle straight.
You have no understanding of the real world.
I don't know why I've invited you on the show in the first place,
except somebody told me you were an expert.
That's,
that's what it means in the public sphere to be a professor.
Uh,
and so,
you know,
Bubba perhaps exaggerates a little bit when he went,
when he,
uh,
he says the discourse of hybridity,
has an element of terrorism about it.
Bob was writing a long ago before nine 11 and so on,
and perhaps uses the term a little loosely,
but have to say,
and,
and I have to say,
when I hear somebody addressing me,
someone not in the academy,
because of course people have content for me in the academy too,
but it's a more complicated thing.
They may not have contempt for other professors,
if you see what I mean.
Uh,
so that's,
that,
that's more complicated.
But when someone not in the academy addresses me at professor as professor,
I suppose I can't say that I feel terrorized.
Exactly.
Um,
but I do feel depressed.
Uh,
and that is,
and,
and that's an important part of the double consciousness of the subaltern as
Baba expatiate.
It's on him.
And then in any case,
finally,
the deconstructive moment of gender theory in which gender is understood not as
something essential,
but as something performed,
something brought into existence,
not just by verbal discourse,
but by all the semiotics systems,
including gesture,
dress and all the rest of it.
That,
uh,
that is,
that,
that constitutes,
uh,
the way in which gender comes into being.
Now,
in each case,
you have instances of knowledge as negation.
I'm just,
I,
I'm just trying to pull this back into the perspective of what we recognize
perhaps more readily as literary theory.
By knowledge as negation.
I mean,
semiotic knowledge.
There's something that I've been trying to stress really,
uh,
as a central theme throughout this course.
I am,
well,
I don't know what I am,
but I'll tell you this,
I'm not that.
All right.
In other words,
the way in which I come to my aunt to understand myself as not that,
and I,
of course,
and the person,
uh,
Oh,
who possesses hedge mnemonic discourse.
So I see myself,
I come to understand myself.
Um,
uh,
for the first time in the argument of a Toni Morrison or an Edwards Pie EAD,
or in a certain sense of a Judith Butler,
I come to understand myself in a way for the first time when I reflect on what
I'm not.
That is to say when I tried to objectify,
uh,
to,
pigeonhole that which I'm not,
which is of course not what I'm really not,
but what I suppose myself not to be.
Uh,
and so in all of these ways,
then you,
and you can see that the way in which according to the sorts of thinking we've
been reviewing in recent weeks,
the way in which one comes to understands oneself is precisely negative in the
tradition of semiotic,
uh,
and formalists understandings of language to I am not at all necessarily what I
am.
I am precisely as I understand,
not that not the other,
uh,
and I grasp myself perhaps in ways,
that deepen my alleged understanding of myself as a result of this negative
process.
All right.
So I say all these things again to reassure you that we still are talking about
literary theory that the uh,
ways of thinking about things that we've encountered recently really do arise
out of issues given to us by deconstruction,
by negation and the semiotic and formalists tradition.
Uh,
and that we can understand what has happened.
Basically this in terms of the overall structure of the course,
we can understand what has happened basically not as a change in the structure
of thought.
We examined when we took up language as the primary determinant of
understanding,
not so much as a change in the structure of thought,
but as a transformation of language,
the determinant of social understanding into what we call a social text so that
our head now is not the repository of so sewers long.
That is something that,
something that just sits there in and of itself as a system,
but it's full of other people's language.
It is a space in which a society itself understood as discourse Jostle's for
attention,
uh,
and struggles,
to somehow or another to shape itself into intelligibility.
That's the fundamental change.
It's language is still preeminent in the kinds of thinking that we've been
doing.
We haven't really gotten away from language but we have altered our
understanding of language.
Language is now a social text.
It is now uh,
in Bach teens words,
other people's language and we understand it.
Therefore not something and of course semiotics and deconstruction don't
understand it as our own either because language always precedes us but we
understand it more clearly as something that is given to us as a social
formation that intern forms us.
And in a way that does bring us to our topic today because uh,
this,
this topic almost the last topic of the course has to do with the preconditions
of interpretation.
What makes it possible for us to think something?
How is it that we come to think one thing as opposed to another thing?
How is it that there are areas of agreement among us?
How is it for that matter that there are areas of disagreement among us entity
that these air,
that these areas characteristically seem to be so non negotiable that you know,
the point arises at which we just can find ourselves in agreement on things.
Just as the point arises when we realized that we are in some profound way in
agreement about other things.
How is it that all of this comes to be in order to do that?
Let's first go back to Tony and think about Tony.
Uh,
once again,
uh,
as being about,
because we've said all along that it's about whatever it is that we happened to
be talking about.
Uh,
let's,
let's think about Tony once again as being about the things we've been
discussing recently.
We can say for example,
that Tony is a Marxist Qantas station of the social determinacy of identity in
other forms.
It's a realist tax because as we've said before,
nothing happens that there is no change in the social formations that are the
givens of the story.
But it nevertheless does lay out the relationships among social norms,
uh,
in ways that show that those,
that,
that life goes on despite social inequality despite,
um,
and of course here,
I'm going to throw something at you that you've had or hadn't thought of so much
in terms of Tony before,
despite ethnic and gender difference.
Now,
what happens then in Tony,
I mean to,
to move to a slightly different way of thinking about it is we can see that it's
a global story masked as a story of hybridity in the American melting pot.
It should have been perfectly plain to you all along that Tony is an Italian
American with the,
with,
with the complex personality of the subaltern.
On the one hand,
he believes in the American dream.
He likes his job.
Uh,
he buys into the system and the other word,
but on the other hand,
he recognizes a kind of,
but he has his own place in the world,
the little Jello garage.
It's his niche in the world.
Uh,
and it's something,
uh,
and it's something that is partly what affords him his identity Nieto.
Of course,
on the other hand is the,
uh,
is,
is the neurotic wasp in the Manor House.
Um,
you know,
sort of representing,
representing that sort of class and speedy very interestingly is what is,
is a member of what John Guillory calls the professional managerial class.
And,
and,
and what's interesting about speedy as that suddenly we realize that his ethnic
origins and his class origins and even his gender,
because he may be a woman,
uh,
are,
not perhaps as relevant as one might have imagined them to be because the
professional managerial class is interesting as Guillory source.
Alvin Goldner,
uh,
points out at length is interesting,
precisely as the emergence of a body of people with common interests who really
can't be said at least to derive from,
uh,
or perhaps in a way even to belong to a common class.
And so a speedy is certainly in Tony the tow truck or representative of this new
emerging class.
Perhaps it's no accident that Nido comes first.
I think memory serves me and saying that neato comes first in the sort of
folkloric triad because Nido represents an older class,
a class,
which in a certain sense is giving way to the professional managerial class so
that it makes sense that first you'd get Nieto and then you would get speedy.
All right.
So then we can also think of of tone.
The tow truck,
of course,
in terms of gender,
uh,
we've said there are no women in it.
At the same time.
You do have those frowning and smiling houses with him,
sort of embodying the angel in the house.
But it's not just that,
I mean,
obviously Nido,
I've never drawn a picture of Neato but with his little bow tie and his prissy,
oh,
I don't want to get dirty.
I mean he's just,
he's just a bundle of gay stereotypes.
And,
and then obviously with,
you know,
bumpy,
he pushes and pushes,
you don't even want to go there.
And so,
and so in any case,
uh,
this is,
this is plainly a story about gender.
Um,
and so,
you know,
you,
you can see that it's about all these things.
All right.
So then here's the question and it really does provide us with our transition to
today's materials.
What have I been doing all this time with Tony?
The tow truck I've been doing exactly as you can see now what fish does with
Jacobs Rosenbaum,
11 thorn Hayes Omen.
I've been showing that if you bring a certain sub position to what you're
reading,
you're going to prefer perform a certain kind of hermaneutic act.
Not with any particular strain,
but more or less spontaneously because that's what you are conditioned to do.
Now,
fishes class,
I had no trouble construing they,
uh,
assignment for his previous class as a poem.
Uh,
and you can see of course,
that it was sort of ready to hand to be construed that way.
Uh,
fish admits that,
but he's a lecturing some people in Kenyon college and he pointed,
he just sort of runs his finger down the college,
the,
the list of faculty names and say,
look what I could do with these names,
you know,
and I,
and,
and I think,
you know,
does make his point because you can do it with absolutely anything we can see of
course,
that his class actually missed a few points.
Uh,
it forgot to mention that,
um,
the,
uh,
an ancient and important meaning of the word 11 is lightning.
So that a flash of revelation is entailed and the,
uh,
in any religious understanding of the Parm,
and it's almost impossible to understand why his class was stumped by the word
haze because Hays,
well,
you know,
we see things through a glass darkly,
we see them in a haze and that's exactly the way in which we're likely to
respond,
uh,
to,
instances of,
of religious revelation as they are given in the devotional poetry of the 17th
century.
So,
in any case,
um,
what we've been doing with Tony,
the tow truck is of this kind.
We've taken a text with a second.
By the way,
you may want to know whether I think Tony is really about something,
you know,
as opposed to about all of those things.
Well,
I actually do and I mentioned it in passing,
but it's not an end to it.
It's only an intuition and it really doesn't arise out of any particular
predilections I have for psychoanalysis.
Uh,
it does seem to me however that a story written to that age group in which the
climactic line is,
he pushed and he pushed and I'm on my way is pretty obviously about one thing as
opposed to a lot of other things.
And that if you really pushed me about what Tony,
the tow truck is about,
I would say,
well,
I think it's an anal phase parable and that,
uh,
and,
and that Robert crouse very possibly wrote it for that purpose.
In other words,
this would engage the attention of the toddler who's being,
who's having the story read to him or her,
uh,
and that its meaningfulness probably is going to come across to the toddler in
that way.
Perhaps in a more and more pronounced fashion than in any other,
certainly,
and obviously in a more pronounced fashion than most of the ways in which we've
been talking about the text.
And so that's what I think.
But what I think also as we'll see,
of course I've disclaimed any connection with psychoanalysis,
but nevertheless and know something about it.
Uh,
and so that's part of my interpretive community.
W W we'll get back to that.
Um,
all right,
so in any case,
we've been treating,
uh,
Tony the tow truck in this way and we have been,
well,
you know,
nodding our heads and say,
yeah,
it's about that too.
And I guess so,
yeah.
Interesting.
Isn't it?
Under what it's going to be about on Thursday?
Uh,
and we've been and,
and,
and we've been doing this because we belong to an interpretive community.
Now I want immediately to add here two caveats.
I would say that within the interpretive community that makes up this room,
a community of people who are interested in interpretation,
probably have all along that interpretation was a Mug's game and therefore
wanted to take a course of this kind to find out how just how bad it was.
Uh,
it all of us at least have in common,
um,
a concern with the potential complexity of those circumstances that surround a
interpretation.
So we are an interpretive interpretive community that's interested in
So we play the game.
However,
I would hazard that within this interpretive community there are two sub
communities,
um,
which probably in a certain sense while they see the significance of the
exercise,
nevertheless want to hold out against.
One of them is the community,
which either has always has or has now come to,
to,
to have,
uh,
a very,
very strong commitment to one or another point of view that's been passed and
review in this course and who therefore finds it demeaning of the important
point of view that it would be treated simply in a survey,
in a serial way with all sorts of other points of view that may or may not
supplant or jostle with it.
Now,
uh,
this is,
um,
th th this takes us back to the remarks.
I was making it the beginning about the way in which one can perhaps acknowledge
the usefulness of a survey course,
but nevertheless bridle at the very idea of a survey course when after all,
the only thing that matters is Marxists thought,
why do we spend any time with all of these other approaches to things?
And so on.
Just sort of which,
whichever form of thought is the only thing that matters to you.
Uh,
and so,
um,
this would probably lead you to say not so much.
Tony is only about this one thing,
but oh,
you know,
this is a really facile and irrelevant exercise because the important thing is
to take this one thing seriously and the implication is that if you take a lot
of other things in review,
uh,
you're not taking this one thing seriously now that's,
so that might be one sub community within our interpretive community and another
one might be a sub community that is committed,
still committed as one's tempted to say to high culture and says,
I think it's a bit,
I think we should have used listed us or the rime of the ancient mariner.
Uh,
it was demeaning to high culture to use Tony the tow truck.
And furthermore,
this sub community might very well say,
um,
if we had used listed as or the rime of the ancient mariner,
a certain approach,
a certain way of reading,
either of those poems would have made sense self evidently meaning that all the
other approaches,
uh,
are trivial.
If you,
if your commitment is not so much to one point of view as to some idea of high
culture,
you're not going to say in advance which approach it is,
but you're going to suppose that somehow or another such as the value in nature
of high culture that it will be possible to arrive at a sort of consensus view
of what's going on in one of its products.
This is what Gillery is talking about.
Uh,
at least in part,
um,
in his,
uh,
review of defenses of Western civilization,
Western culture and so on.
They have a meaning.
They have a continuity,
they have a stability,
uh,
which is worth preserving and which ought to be the central business of the
schools to promulgate.
All right?
So,
um,
those are possible sub communities within our interpretive community,
but we all do have in common the recognition that it's possible to riff on a
text in this way.
Uh,
and if somebody does it,
we recognize that whether we like it or not,
we ourselves could probably do it too.
So that the,
which has proof from Stanley Fischer's point of view and also from John Gillery
is pointed to because we're in a school,
uh,
that we,
um,
have a great deal in common and that it's what we have in common that brings the
text into visibility in the variety of ways,
uh,
that we've performed on it.
Now,
with all of this said,
let's talk a little bit more about what an interpreter interpretive community is
a for first according to Stanley fish.
Um,
and,
and then move to the point where we may wish to suggest one form or another of
criticism of this idea.
Let's begin with fishes.
First sentence,
uh,
which is on page 10,
23,
the upper left hand column.
Okay.
This is a series of lectures.
And so he begins by saying,
last time I sketched out an argument by which meanings are the property,
neither of fixed and stable text,
nor of free and independent readers,
but of interpretive communities that are responsible both for the shape of a
reader's activities and for the texts those activities produce.
I don't know that he's written that he really carries his argument all that much
farther forward in this lecture,
which is why,
um,
I think it's worthwhile to begin with the sentence because in some ways it does
anticipate,
uh,
what he then lays out,
once more in this lecture.
Now,
an interesting thing about the career of Stanley fish as that he actually,
uh,
in the course of that are quite high visibility career changed his mind twice.
Uh,
and his changes of mind are actually recorded residually in this essay that you
read.
How do we recognize a poem when we see one,
which by the way,
as a completely disingenuous title because we don't see poems.
Uh,
that's,
that's the whole,
that's the whole point.
There's no poem there.
I mean,
if it's there,
it's because you put it there.
Uh,
and,
but,
but in any case,
um,
uh,
in this,
these changes of mind,
our residually present in this text,
uh,
they are actually manifest in the peculiar vagary of the argument of an earlier
essay he wrote called interpreting the Variorum,
which is what was in the second edition of Rector.
And is the one that I used to teach.
Uh,
but I think it's still worth hearkening back to those changes of mind.
Um,
when I was his student at the University of California,
um,
he held his first opinion.
This was just before he published,
surprised by sin.
The reader in paradise lost a book for,
for which a seminar that I was in was a kind of Guinea pig.
Um,
and,
uh,
to give you an example of what he meant by saying that a stable text produces a
reader.
In other words that,
that I do,
which is,
which was his first belief.
I'll give you an example that he uses from Milton about Satan spear.
This is a Satan standing by the fiery lake.
He's just pulled himself up to his full height.
Um,
he has a spear,
uh,
and Milton writes about it,
his spear to equal which the tallest pine.
Okay.
Spear Pine,
about the same size.
A human to be the master of some great amaryl.
Well,
let's see.
Mass Pine Spear.
We're about a won.
And then you realize that the sequence of sizes is completely reversed.
Um,
and what you thought,
what you'd already filled your consciousness with the tallest pine.
You know,
it's just a wand.
Compare it with the size of Satan spirits.
So what's he saying?
He's saying you think that your mind can grasp the magnitude of Satan.
You think you know how big Satan is,
but the language of paradise lost is going to teach you,
is going to educate you into realizing don't mess with Satan because Satan is
much bigger than you think.
He is.
What I didn't write here,
and what continues the passage shows that even here,
Satan is absolutely at his weakest.
The passage continues.
He walked with to support an easy steps and others,
he's just risen from the fiery lake.
He says week is he's ever going to be right now and yet he's already a lot more
than you can handle.
Okay?
So that and that is the way the syntax of paradise lost educates us into
realizing that every time we think we grasp for the point of a text,
we prove that we are fallen readers,
that we have prematurely understood what's there and that only understanding it
in the long run can prevail on,
can prevail upon us to realize,
uh,
the fallen condition,
which the text is obviously after all about that was fishes first opinion.
Not Too long after that,
uh,
in the course of writing a book called self consuming artifact,
he began to have a different opinion,
which more or less reverse the first one they decided it isn't the text that
brings the reader into being.
That is to say brings about the self realization on my part that I'm a fall and
being in the case of paradise lost,
it isn't the tax that brings the reader into existence.
It's the reader that brings the text into existence.
It's the reader after all,
who performed this act of reading.
And it's the reader who made visible in the text the possibility that this is
what Milton is doing.
So he reverses his field while retaining the same structure of argument in the
same range of insight about what one can think about a text.
Well that was fine until he realized that,
you know,
a reader has to come from someplace,
arena isn't just an autonomous being.
And he said,
well as a mat and,
and,
and this is where the,
he realized that the third step in his development,
his second change of mind means this.
It's not the text that produces the reader.
It's not the reader that produces the text,
but it's the community that produces the reader who in turn produces the text.
Those three points.
In other words,
um,
our,
uh,
our map,
the progress of his thinking on these issues.
It's quick.
Look at page 10,
25,
the right hand column.
He says in bottom of the paragraph,
interpretation is not the art of construing,
but the art of constructing interpreters do not d code poems.
They make them.
Okay.
When he says that he's at,
he's only at phase two of his thinking because there's still the possibility
open to the reader of thinking that the interpreter is an autonomous being whose
thoughts,
who's interpretive powers,
whose strategies of reading,
uh,
emanate from something from within.
But then,
uh,
on page 10,
27,
he clarifies,
uh,
toward the bottom of the right hand column.
This does not,
however,
commit me to subjectivity.
In other words,
it's not just a question of,
um,
whatever I think is in a text as in a text.
I'm the one who makes the text and you make the text and the other person makes
the text.
We all make different texts because we all have different subjectivities.
That's not what he's saying.
This does not,
however,
commit me to subjectivity because the means by which they are made are social
and conventional.
I can't have an off the wall interpretation of anything if anyone else ever
hears it.
Yeah.
If I,
if I,
if I'm just,
if,
if I'm just in my room surrounded by yellow wallpaper or something like that,
I suppose I can have an off the wall interpretation of something.
But if I try to publish it,
forget it.
When I try to publish,
when I try to express myself,
when I exposed myself to any aspect of the public's fear,
my interpretation,
if it's to be judged as an interpretation as all at all,
if it's to count as an interpretation,
if it's to count as an opinion,
must already be immeshed in the interpretive community to which it's addressed,
it must have some sort of link with that community.
It must involve some sort of membership or relationship with that community so
that what fish concludes as that there are neither subjects nor objects.
In other words,
this is fishes way,
uh,
following Derrida and deconstruction of attacking them.
Western metaphysical tradition.
As long as we suppose that understanding is a matter of parsing or coming to
terms with subject object relations,
we're on the wrong track to understanding and we have to understand,
uh,
the way in which neither the subject nor the object can be said to have a stable
existence,
to have integrity of any kind before we can come closer to grasping how it is
that interpretation is made and achieved.
We've seen this before,
all the way back at the beginning of the semester when we talked about for
having,
uh,
in Heidegger and got him or about the way in which we always see something as
something,
we never see it as an object.
We never see it in an of itself.
We've seen it before,
but there is a slight difference because Heidegger and got and got them or hold
out the object as a standard against one's opinions about it can be tested.
In other words,
the hermaneutic circle is a movement back and forth between interpretation and
what's being interpreted.
So that what's being interpreted is a constant check on the process of
interpretation.
Just as interpretation as a deepens,
uh,
is a finer and finer outlining of the nature of the object.
So the hermaneutic circle,
which resembles which anticipates the thinking of fish in that it insists on the
way in which all interpretation begins as preconception.
Nevertheless does also entail that subtle difference in that the object is
there.
It's not that fish denies the existence of objects.
Sometimes.
Sometimes his rhetoric makes it seem that way.
It's not that he denies the existence of logic,
he simply denies that we can know them as objects at any point.
They,
we bring them into being and in bringing them into being,
we construct them in whatever way it is that we construct them now.
Okay.
Interpretive Communities.
What do we make of this idea of interpretive community?
I've just said we all belonged to an interpretive community.
We sitting here all belonged to an interpretive community.
Um,
there may be a couple of sub communities,
but basically we're an interpretive community.
We understand each other and yet at the same time
it's equally the case.
As I'm sure all of you are thinking to yourselves that no one of us has exactly
the same set of opinions as anyone else.
We say we belonged to an interpretive community.
We can in fact,
according to a certain weak form of the argument,
understand the way in which yes,
we do bring things into being according to certain habits that have evolved
through our membership in such a community.
But at the same time we say,
guess what?
You know,
I don't quite interpret James Rosenbaum and the rest of them in the way fishes
class did.
I still don't interpret it in a way that professor fry supplemented their
interpretation.
Um,
I interpreted a little differently and furthermore,
I knew all along it wasn't a poem.
Uh,
you know,
I,
you can't fool me.
Uh,
and so on.
Um,
so and you,
and so each of us say to ourselves,
okay,
yeah,
we have certain things in common,
but there are also ways in which we differ.
What would fish say to that?
I,
I think what he would say is this.
And I,
and I do think,
and I think this needs to be acknowledged,
it weakens his position.
They would say,
all right,
granted in some,
in a rough sense,
we belong here.
Just as John Guillory says,
in a rough sense,
we're all in a
and a rough sense.
We belonged to an interpretive community,
but there's another sense in which we are each of us,
the sum total,
the composite of all the interpretive communities to which we now,
uh,
in some way or another,
have an affinity and from which in a v in all the variety of ways one can
mention we have emerged.
Yes,
we're each different because the,
some of the interpretive communities to which we belong constituting the
ultimate interpretive community that indeed we are,
is always going to be a little different from the sum of the,
of the communities to which other people belong.
This reduces the idea of interpretive community to a kind of atomism whereby we
all concede.
We all say,
yes,
it's true.
I am in a certain sense,
a community.
Uh,
that's all Buckstein's said.
I am a community.
And of course what communities do when they think is interpret thinking is
interpretation,
but at the same time,
what's the point?
We then say,
I'm saying I'm a community.
If in fact I'm a little different from everybody else,
why not retain a certain sense of subjectivity,
uh,
or why not at least,
retain that sense of individuality,
which results from the fact that none of us ultimately completely on every
particular agree with anybody else.
The reason being that the sum of our interpretive communities that makes up that
fundamental community to which we say we belong is always a little bit
different.
Okay.
Now there is another argument against,
uh,
this position,
the of what,
which might be called radical constructivism.
Uh,
we hear it very frequently from a socio biological thinkers like Edward O.
Wilson for example.
Uh,
who think that,
who pointed out that consciousness is hardwired to do and to recognize all sorts
of things.
Uh,
we,
it has been shown in the lab that aesthetic preference,
which of course was always held just to up to derision,
has anything like an objective,
standard aesthetic preference.
You know,
there's no disputing tastes we always say,
but even aesthetic preference,
it's been shown in the lab involves certain predilections.
We all do have in common,
we all prefer the so called golden section.
We Love Arches and this can be explained and all sorts of ways.
The most common explanation has to do with what's called shelter theory.
We liked shapes that somehow or another offer shelter or protection.
Uh,
but in any case,
uh,
the fairly conclusive evidence is that in a variety of ways we are hardwired to
recognize things.
Darwin's last book is all about how we recognize the each other's expressions.
We recognize the expressions of animals that with which we have a great deal in
common and that we do this from infancy.
Uh,
in other words,
all sorts of evidence to this effect.
But you know,
I'm not sure fishes argument is vulnerable to that position because after all,
hard wiring is communitarian.
The point is precisely that we all have it.
And then it's not something that we can call individual,
not something that we can call or something,
something autonomous to any one of us as individuals.
So it seems to me that although that the argument,
the argument against so called radical constructivism usually does take this
form.
It seems to me that it actually not a very good argument.
Uh,
and that the argument objecting to the mirror weakness of the way in which
interpretive community as a concept ultimately becomes out of atomistic,
uh,
as a stronger argument because what does it matter if I'm an interpretive
community,
if I'm still a community of one,
uh,
there in some measure,
um,
it's,
it's something that seems less worth talking about once,
once put it in those terms.
All right.
Very quickly then on Guillory,
uh,
whose argument,
um,
actually ended the very debate that he thinks is going to intensify and get
worse.
In other words,
he thought that the big hot button topic in the,
in the academic world for the next 25 years or more would be the,
the Canon wars,
the,
you know,
the sort of,
sort of canonical non-canonical,
uh,
cultural multicultural.
He thought he thought this would be the fundamental point of contention and the
academic world.
Well,
it wasn't,
and there isn't.
It wasn't is that his argument was so brilliant.
Everybody came to their senses and realize that they were barking up the wrong
tree.
I mean,
literally his book,
Cultural Capital,
uh,
simply silenced,
not in the public because nothing ever silence as the public,
but simply but,
but,
but simply silenced,
uh,
the debate about the culture wars in the academy.
Um,
and so in some ways,
um,
Guillory,
amusingly a undermines his own prophecy,
which by the way is on page 1477 and the upper right hand column,
if you care to read it now,
um,
Gillery his main preoccupation,
which he takes largely from Pierre Butcher,
but also as he argues in a long constructive digression from Antonio Gramsci.
His main preoccupation is with the school as a means of establishing and
proliferating what grom she called hegemony the school.
In other words,
on this argument doesn't typically,
and we'll,
we'll come back to the exception that gallery himself does make the school
doesn't typically
send out into the world.
Mine's armed with specific bodies of knowledge or understanding it sends out
into the world,
especially when it's a question of the humanities,
which Guillory thinks are painting themselves into the corner,
uh,
in their obtuseness.
Uh,
especially when it's a matter of the humanities.
The school sends out into the world,
people endowed with a certain quantum of cultural capital.
It repeats,
in other words,
in board years term,
it reproduces a structure of class,
uh,
but really class in the sort of super sad,
super structural sense class superiority,
uh,
that regardless of the specific content that a person's supposed as himself to
have been mastering,
uh,
that is,
that simply replicates a,
an orientation to the ruling class,
uh,
that the school,
in a western culture according to Gillery has always had what the school
reproduces,
is not knowledge so much as itself,
the attitude that it embodies its reason for being,
uh,
it's reason for continuation and its relation to power and stay state apparatus.
That's galleries up basic position and it's why he says that the culture wars,
um,
uh,
I simply play into the hands of the Monolithic ideology of the school.
What happens when you embrace multiculturalism as the only a means of
inculcating what Guillory calls progressive pedagogy.
What happens when you embrace multiculturalism according to Gillery is that you
d Ras innate the object of your intake,
of your intention from the culture to which they belong in precisely the way
that the great monuments of Western civilization have long since been
deracinated from their historical and cultural circumstances.
You reduce both western Civ and alternative cannons to the same deracinated
rootless,
uh,
sort of nature as cultural capital.
I have read this,
I have a certain status and negotiability in the world as having read this.
Uh,
in the case of Western Civ,
uh,
it's quotations from the poets and after dinner speeches in the case of
multicultural curricula,
that's the opportunity to allude in precisely the same way on largely the same
occasions.
And in either case,
it has nothing to do with learning anything about according to Gillery about the
historical and social circumstances in which any kind of cultural production,
uh,
are grounded.
Now the,
um,
the argument,
uh,
depends of course on supposing that,
the way in which the way in which the great works are taught is as though they
embodied certain ideas or principles.
That is to say they're taught as messages in Gillery his view,
uh,
whatever form of message it might be.
Uh,
the western Canon as a message about the importance of being an American,
the,
uh,
mult multicultural canons as a message,
a contestatory message about the importance of being whoever happens to be
speaking.
Uh,
but in each case,
they're merely messages.
They're not cultural artifacts.
They are,
they don't emerge from the real sort of historical and living circumstances in
which they're written.
Now,
this is,
uh,
at which,
which of course is,
is,
is most broadly speaking,
uh,
simply an appeal to method,
a new way of teaching Gillery his own deepest commitment is in fact to the great
works.
Guillory began as an early modern scholar.
He wrote a very,
very fine first book on Spencer and Milton.
Uh,
his later work and literary sociology,
uh,
in no ways discredits or undermines the fact that earlier in his career he was
interested in a cultural canon.
Uh,
and in fact,
in fact,
probably the most interesting chapter in Po in cultural capital is maybe not
this,
uh,
the introductory theoretical one,
but an amazing chapter in which he shows how a graze Thomas Gray's elegy in a
country churchyard,
uh,
came to predominate in English curricula,
even though it was written in the vernacular in English.
He shows,
in other words,
how the allergy and a country churchyard,
uh,
in the way in which it's situated itself in culture at that time actually
undermined the premium placed on the classics on La Teneti,
uh,
and helped,
the emergence of a,
uh,
vernacular national curriculum.
It's an absolutely brilliant argument in which the LG in a country churchyard is
itself constantly and steadily and fascinatingly invoked.
In other words,
Guillory himself likes the classics.
Uh,
and,
and perhaps the most interesting part of this argument is the way in which,
uh,
the western Civ Mavens,
um,
are simply fooled about their own understanding of what a Canon is.
Because perpetually history changes candidates.
Uh,
the more books you get,
the fewer you can read and the more it gets dropped out of any curriculum,
including the western Civ curse curriculum today.
You know,
we're proud if we're proponents of great books,
we're proud of reading Plato and Aristotle.
Uh,
in the old days,
people didn't stop with Plato and Aristotle.
They read everything there was to read in Greek and Latin culture.
Um,
and then they read such few books as may have been published in English.
Well,
a great deal has happened since then.
And perforce,
uh,
modern modern languages and literatures have,
have altered the cannon always to the,
to the end of thinning it out.
More and more gets left out.
This is an inevitability even in the so-called canonical and therefore itself
needs to acknowledge the centrality of historical change.
Gillery his argument obviously hinges on the failure of anybody involved in
these debates to,
to distinguish between the two forms of culture.
There's culture,
the guide of culture on which a person without any educated at all education at
all and the new professional managerial class can meet the kind of culture in
which precisely literature,
it doesn't matter who needs literature,
you know,
I'm running Hewlett Packard,
do I need literature?
Um,
you know,
uh,
and,
and uh,
at the same time the kind of culture which,
you know,
with a capitalK as we say,
uh,
it,
which is all about,
uh,
the great books,
high culture,
uh,
the monuments of civilization and so on.
Guillory says the total disconnect,
uh,
in the way in which we understand the relations between these two forms of
culture is what leads to the kinds of deracination in teaching that he complains
about.
He himself finally thinks that anything is fair game to be taught and it can be
taught progressively as long as it is taught in terms of its social and
historical circumstances.
He points out that a great book.
I will quote this and then I'll leave you.
He points out that a great book is great in part because it can't possibly be
reduced to the silliness that the advocates of western Civ attached to it.
He says,
paid 1482 right hand column.
No cultural work of any interest at all is simple enough to be credibly
allegorizing in this way because any cultural work will objectify,
and it's very form and content,
the same social conflict that the Canon debate allegorize is by means of a Dura,
a divided curriculum.
The Odyssey is full of lying,
trickery,
class,
betrayal,
the Iliad.
Perhaps the most interesting character,
as I'm sure you'll all agree,
is their psyches who is scarcely and advocate of the values that we associate
with Western culture.
Uh,
and so in any case,
this is what Guillory means.
Uh,
by saying that you cannot monumentalize anything in this way if you read it
carefully and attentively enough.
So ultimately it's simply a program for reading.
Okay.
Next time we'll talk about,
uh,
the idea that we shouldn't have theory at all.